the trade control and expert system
known as traces is an online management
tool of the European Commission that
tracks the movements of animals food
feed and plants imported from outside
the EU or traveling through the
countries of the European Union each
year vast quantities of livestock and
produce are traded into the European
Union to be served on 500 million
European plates raising the question how
can the European Commission ensure that
both food and consumers are kept safe
the European Commission requires
consignments to be accompanied by health
certificates or trade documents and
national authorities may post these
documents online through traces in
addition border control authorities must
check all of the certificates to allow a
consignment to enter and travel through
each European Member State when animals
and animal products vegetables and
plants even wood and organic products
and feed and food of non animal origin
as well are exported to the European
Union
Tracie's manages the official controls
and route planning quickly and
efficiently online
the system manages and monus's thousands
of documents which significantly reduces
the administrative burden on economic
operators and governmental authorities
in simple terms the moment of economic
operator decides to export a consignment
of goods it enters the necessary data
into the Tracie's system more than
25,000 users worldwide connect to traces
to track consignments in 33 languages 24
hours a day seven days a week
generating 1 million emails per day and
more than 1 million certificates per
year and each year online traces manages
500,000 intra-union trade certificates
and 500,000 border control documents so
when a consignment is declared at a
European Union border everyone concerned
from economic operator to control
Authority can check the certificates
through the same information system
greatly simplifying and accelerating the
entire trading process
during transportation the journey each
can sign man takes is carefully
specified and monitored and like
individual footprints this tracking
creates traceability so should there be
a problem with an animal or product the
system quickly tracks back to the
original source of the problem and
forward to the destination by tracking
importation flows precisely however
complex a route might be traces can
respond quickly to problems providing
both consumers and livestock with
greater security and protection plus by
quickly detecting abnormalities in data
the system helps prevent fraudulent
trading in fact 70 countries now
participate in traces 28 European Union
38 non European Union and for EFTA
countries to facilitate exports to and
through Europe in short traces
encourages cooperation and facilitates
trading from farm to fork
and using traces will become even more
quick and easy in the near future by
2015 traces aims to stop using paper
everything will be available digitally
even signatures and you'll be able to
operate the system on tablets and mobile
phones too
traces is a major leap forward in
tracking the movements of livestock and
produce monitoring animal diseases and
combating fraud whilst significantly
speeding up administrative procedures
traces protecting consumers facilitating
trade
Oh